the creator of the best text adventure
game ever has disappeared this is a
story of the quest to find her in 1982
Time Magazine's Man of the Year was the
machine of the year the personal
computing revolution was in full swing
what was once a massive machine
exclusively for scientists was now small
enough to invade people's homes and
lives the Commodore 64 led the charge
its advanced computing power and wild
popularity challenged developers across
the world to make bigger and better
video games one small team in Australia
set an ambitious goal to create the best
text adventure game ever made remember
back then there were no computer Mouse's
just keyboards and words
so what could set them up for success
adapting one of the biggest fantasy
stories of all time The Hobbit our story
starts in Melbourne Australia with this
man
Alfred Milgram a video game pioneer in
those days we were still trying to
define what a computer game was there
weren't any guidelines there wasn't a
pool of people who knew about games are
Winton pine people from Melbourne
University two students joined the team
film was the programmer for the game
Veronica was the one who created the
puzzles she's the one who took the text
of The Hobbit and turned it into an
adventure game and she did a brilliant
job the game begins with a simple
sentence you are in the comfort of
then the player types in commands to
move about an open world in 1982 simple
games like pac-man were coming out but
Veronica and Phil were creating a
complex digital universe almost
immediately was a huge hit people were
having parties to play The Hobbit
overall we ended up selling something
like quarter of a million copies but one
thing was missing Veronica Veronica we
lost touch not long after the Hobbit was
published do you know what happened her
no idea did Veronica know her game was a
worldwide phenomenon that she had super
fans in Russia in England in Spain that
people were learning English just to
play the game
my name is this is Martina Davis and I
love video games for me how it was the
beginning of a new world the world and
microcomputer and the wall of Tokyo it
was a turning point for me I always
wanted to contact the people that was
behind the game and hey Zeus he wasn't
the only one fans from all over the
world were searching for Veronica she
wasn't really missing but it was the
1980s they had no way to get in touch
with her until the birth of the Internet
with a quick search fans now had
Veronica's email address and hey Zeus
was one of the first to write to her
[Music]
dear Veronica your game attains my life
I learnt English because of your game
thank you for making the Hobbit all
those years ago with Phillip Mitchell
aloe vera Nica dear Veronica the woman
that shaped my life Hobbit game did and
still does mean a great deal of it
many thanks for the countless hours of
entertaining I hope karma has rewarded
you in your life for writing that game
because for all the price off page and
I'm still paying for all the rejections
in isolation being a geek is indeed what
I am what I love to be and what I'll
always be proud to be thank you
pS escaping the goblin dungeon was a
nightmare
[Music]
that's not amazing
I'm dr. Veronica negra the quest ends in
Portland Oregon at okyun ask landscape
where Veronica leads a normal life I
really had no idea of how popular the
game was up until about ten years ago it
was a part-time job I did at University
and I moved on to bigger and better
things my PhD is in computer science I
built a big data such engine that
combines ideas from cognitive science
and internet search to work over
archives of scientific data I am NOT a
gamer after I wrote The Hobbit I didn't
play any games at all
for probably a decade it wasn't just the
fan mail that drew Veronica out of the
shadows there's a lot of women who don't
realize that they can also be computer
programmers puppet
[Music]
this is my legacy and that was part of
the push to me to start stepping forward
and making myself easier to find just to
help correct that gender bias it's
pretty amazing how far that game reached
and just blows me away and it was a
part-time job at University who wasn't
expecting to change an industry my task
was write the best text adventure
computer game ever
and I did
[Music]